[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Welcome back to 8.20.
In this section, you want to
look at light, what is it,
and how does it propagate.
In this video, specifically,
I give you a little bit
of a preview of 8.02.
And I don't do this in
a very topological way.
I just give you
some information.
So if we study 8.02, we'll
see Maxwell equations
are being developed in there.
We look at Maxwell equations
for electric and magnetic field
E and B in vacuum.
We can rewrite the
Maxwell equations
and define wave equations.
The solutions of
the wave equation,
as the name tells
you, are waves.
So what we are
looking at here is
you want to describe
the propagation
of electric and magnetic
fields in vacuum.
In this situation, this is maybe
at some time, t equal to 0,
we have an electric
field in this point here,
and a magnetic field--
electric field points
into the y direction,
the magnetic field
into the z direction.
And what the
equations now describe
is how the wave propagates
in space and in time.
And you can already tell
from the name, wave equation,
the solutions of this equation--
these differential
sines and cosines.
So one solution here
is are Ey equal to E0,
times cosine, kx minus omega t.
We find then that the speed
in which the wave propagates--
you pick one peak
of a wave, and you
see how it propagates--
one point of variance
here propagates.
The speed in which it propagates
is the speed of light, c.
And you can find c here through
those constants in the Maxwell
equations and wave equations.
Find c is 1 over square
root epsilon 0 and mu 0.
The permeativity and
the permeability,
the product of the two gives
you the speed of light.
So if you look at
this some more,
and connect the Maxwell
equation to the Lorentz force,
again, as a reminder, for
those who had had 8.02 already,
the force on the
charged particle
in an electromagnetic
field is given by 2 times
E, plus 2 times V cross B.
If you have two charges, the
force between those two charges
is the product of the 2
divided by r squared, times 1
over 4 pi x mu 0.
Again, [INAUDIBLE].
And the force
between two wires--
this current-- current
i1 and current i2--
is equal to the product of the
two currents, divided by r,
times l-- the length
of the wires--
times mu 0 over 2 pi.
So this is fantastic,
because now you
can calculate the
speed of light by just
measuring the forces
between charges
and current in wire's centers.
The value of c is
also very interesting.
It's large-- very large.
3 times 10 to the 8
meters per second.
So just let that sink in.
We, as humans, move with
a few meters per second.
Light travels-- a few
nanoseconds is needed for light
to travel about 1 meter.
It takes just nanosecond.
Let's stop the video here.
The next thing I want
to do is an exercise.
I want to have you play with
this differential equation,
and there's a solution of
the differential equation.
But the challenge
or the exercise
is to show that if you have a
function which you can write
as f0, which is an
arbitrary function, which
is a function of x minus
ct, those functions,
regardless in how
they look like,
are solutions of this
differential equation.
Note that I replaced our
constant epsilon 0 and mu
0 now with 1 over c squared.
So f0 can really be
an arbitrary function.
You need to be able to build
the derivative, though.
So I do the function
here as a function
of x for some time equal t0.
And then I drew the same
function 4 times equal to 1.
And so you can,
from this picture,
see that the delta x over delta
t is minus c in this case.
So my function-- my wave is
moving with the speed of light
in minus direction.
So I want you to show that this
kind of equation [INAUDIBLE]
wave equation.
So I would like you to do
this, and stop the video,
and show you the solution next.
So the way to approach this is
simply applying the chain rule.
And that might be something
you want to remind yourself of.
So after I do this, I'll define
this little helper function
here u is equal to x minus ct.
And this makes our
function a function
of u, which is itself
a function of x and t.
So if I built a
derivative with x,
I have this df of
u, du times du dx.
If I build a second
derivative, there
is a product you
have to take care of.
So I find that d is the second
derivative of f of u here,
times du dx squared.
And then I have to add df du
times second derivative of u.
This follows very similar
for the derivative of t.
And then I can
investigate what we find.
So my du dx is equal to 1--
du dx.
If I build the derivative of
x minus et, this x, I find 1.
I do the same with t--
I find minus c.
I will use this second
derivatives of u.
x and t are all 0.
If I put this now
in my equation,
I find second derivative of
f with u is of 1 minus c--
sorry, 1 minus 1 over c squared
times c squared is equal to 0.
And since this is
always 0, we have just
proven that any sort
of function which
I can build the derivative of
which is of the from x minus ct
solves that equation.